so biology comes out he says I will take
that bet you buy one Bitcoin and I'll
I'll send one million dollars to an
escrow
to be clear This is 40 to 1 odds so he's
basically saying not only is this
unlikely to happen like if this was even
odds it would have been like dang
biology is going to lose a million
dollars because bitcoin's not likely to
be worth a million dollars then he added
in 90 days which is already a radical
move then he said
I'm and by the way the million dollars
versus one Bitcoin Bitcoin is currently
at 26 000 at this at the time he made
this bet he goes That's 40 to 1 odds
that I'm laying you
[Music]
foreign
we got an episode here with pomp Anthony
pompliano who you may know as the
Bitcoin guy he's huge all over YouTube
Twitter everywhere else he uh came on
we're actually going to do this as a
two-part episode because at the
beginning it was all business we were
business in the front we were talking
about this crazy million dollar biology
bet where he's betting that Bitcoin is
going to a million dollars in the next
90 days we talk about that why biology
thinks it what we think about the BET
and pomp does a you know I don't know
econ 101 where he explains what's going
on with the banking system from his
perspective that was good and here's the
thing though in that episode the whole
episode is about something that's going
to happen inside the next 90 days so if
you're gonna like it is a little fearful
listening to it and so actually listen
to the whole thing because and do it now
because we're talking about something
that's happening in 90 days and then go
ahead the second episode was way more
fun and it was pretty wild go ahead we
talk about his business Empire you know
what he's building and why he's building
it that way why he gave back all the
money from his fund and shut that down
why he is huge turned off all his
advertisers millions of dollars of
advertised what he's doing instead so we
talked about that and then we talked
about and then it went off the wall and
uh the the Pod got a little crazy but in
a great way I think people are gonna
You're Gonna Love part two
he broke down like all of his businesses
and how they work it's very impressive
it was pretty wild
um and uh it was it was he's impressive
he's significantly more impressive than
a lot of people think I think because
there's way more behind the scenes
pretty funny stories which pop is
usually he's pretty buttoned up on his
on his main Channel because he's talking
Finance he's talking serious but he told
some pretty funny stories so the second
uh part two is the more fun episode part
one is the more serious episode I think
you'll like them both and we have to
remind you guys that our episodes we
work really really hard and unlike every
other type of podcast Out There Our
stuff's not free but you don't pay with
money all you have to do is go to our
YouTube page we call this the
gentleman's agreement what is it the
ladies understanding the ladies
understanding you go to our YouTube page
and the reason it's called that is
because it's an understanding it's an
agreement we can't be there behind your
screen to check this otherwise we would
but everyone's doing it so just go ahead
and do it and click subscribe on YouTube
and then just go ahead and do that on
Spotify and iTunes because
the more you do that the more our volume
goes up and we get more downloads and we
could do keep doing this type of stuff
pump ain't gonna come on to episodes
like this if we don't have a big
listenership same with all the other
guests all right enjoy
um pop we're live by the way we we
always just jump right into this thing
no small talk
let's go what do you guys want to talk
about dude you're I'm so glad you're
here you are you are the Ryan Seacrest
of the of the industry you are the
hardest working man and content
entertainment I'm so glad you're not
doing your like 5 a.m show anymore
um
I'm sure you're also pretty glad you're
not doing that every morning how does it
feel to get some sleep
I've always slept uh pretty well but the
content stuff is um it's the best way in
the world to learn you put information
ideas out there and the people who agree
or have like things to add they're super
constructive and they respond to emails
they tweet at you they do all that stuff
and then the people who vividly disagree
they make their voice heard you know
very well and so you like quickly figure
out like good ideas bad ideas and then
you also get all these like rabbit holes
to go down and I think that probably the
reason why you know YouTube myself and
many of the other people that we all
know and spent a lot of time talking to
we enjoy it like the internet is this
amazing thing that we all get to use on
a daily basis and so uh creating content
I found is just this great way to uh to
elicit like-minded people and uh and to
learn so I was uh Pop I we have a lot to
talk about and we'll do like a proper
intro in a second but I was talking to
my friend Jason yanowitz who you guys
used to work together he works for you
now he has his own company and Jason
works pretty hard he told me that you
were the hardest person allowance used
to work for you
uh he he uh him and his partner Mikey
Polito they were uh the two guys who
helped me start the podcast initially
they uh they tricked me they literally
came to me and they were like uh hey you
should have a podcast and I was like
what's a podcast and they were like you
know like all these other examples and
then I was like I don't know how to do
that they're like well we do and little
did I know they had no clue what they
were doing they instead convinced me to
do a podcast and then they dm'd I'm
pretty sure Gary vaynerchuk's like
podcast guy and it was like Hey we're
gonna start a podcast like what
equipment do we need it's like kudos to
those guys I was pretty good hustle and
now they have a media company that does
tens of millions of dollars whatever it
worked out and Jason works pretty hard
um Jason told me that you're the hardest
working person he's ever been with he
said that they used to work at your
office seven days a week and that you
just for Non-Stop but then when I went
out to dinner with you recently you told
me your schedule it didn't sound very
hard it sounded just normal so which is
it which is true uh I think it's
probably both so one of the things I
always use as a framework is uh there's
kind of gas and breaks in life and so at
certain points you need to hit the gas
and other times you can kind of like let
your foot off the gas Coast as the car
and then other times you need to hit the
brake and knowing when to hit the gas
when to hit the brake uh is pretty
important actually you don't want to
kind of be hitting the gas when there's
a wall in front of you like you want to
make sure you uh are able to kind of go
all in when uh when it's necessary but
the second thing is you got to last
right you can't just Sprint all the time
no matter how athletic you are you got
to have some level of endurance and so
that's probably one of the things that
I've really uh learned to do over the
years I wasn't great at the beginning
now I'm probably pretty good at it but
you know we're recording this on Monday
yesterday was Sunday I record a podcast
Sunday morning at you know 11 o'clock in
the morning after I did a two-hour
meeting with a friend at nine a.m and a
lot of people are like that sounds crazy
but I'm like no what did you do you like
went and did all your hobbies I have no
Hobbies I literally hang out with my
family and I work but I do it because I
enjoy it and so if you enjoy doing it
like this isn't hard I'm like looking
forward to today talking to YouTube
because I'm like you know what they're
probably going to be ridiculous probably
gonna have a lot of fun and we're gonna
learn something from each other like how
lucky are the three of us
two out of three ain't bad so let's uh
we gotta get to this crazy biology bet
and then I'm gonna ask you what you're
doing with your life after that because
I think well do you need a little Empire
you have to set the stage for who he is
right
uh who pomp is okay so let's start with
who pop is so uh I think you're known as
like the Bitcoin guy I would say that's
the that's kind of how you built your
brand you've obviously done a lot more
than that before that I think you worked
at Facebook and even Snapchat for a
little quick lunch and uh and and so you
worked in Tech you uh started to build a
big following on Twitter around crypto
and Bitcoin uh built one of the bigger
like newsletters and brands in that
space and since then launched a bunch of
like you know uh businesses around it so
you had a VC you sort of had your own
you know VC fund or you worked at least
fun then launch your own you uh have
like a kind of like a crypto jobs
company you have a bunch of things in
that ecosystem since then I think you've
you've made some changes now so I want
to hear about those in a bit but then we
have this biology bet and uh pop why
don't you just give us the quick 60
seconds on who biology is and then we'll
we'll frame what this what this crazy
bet is and then I have some inside info
also all right so I don't want to be a
spokesperson for Balaji so everything I
say is my opinion uh this is my
description of him this is my
description of the BET
um but Balaji srinivasan uh is probably
best known now uh for being one of the
more uh kind of public figures to have
predicted a lot of what happened for
kovid uh he was very early calling out
hey this is a risk if this risk becomes
a reality here's how bad it could get
and you know again as with predictions a
lot of it was right some of it was wrong
but generally I think people point back
and they're like man we should have
listened to that guy he then went on
like a two or three year heater where he
kept making predictions and kept being
right about a lot of things and so the
internet kind of uh rallied around this
idea of like the worst words to ever
hear was Balaji was right and so when
you build that type of uh kind of
following and that type of uh reputation
now people put a lot of weight when you
say something and so his latest thing is
Bitcoin is going to hit a million
dollars in the next 90 days which sounds
absolutely insane bitcoin's trading at
twenty seven thousand dollars it's like
you know whatever 40x from here and to
do it in 90 days like we've never seen
an asset really ever do that before
now I don't agree that that is highly
likely I would put it at like maybe I
don't know five percent chance which is
actually much higher than probably most
people would put it uh but to me the
most interesting part is like the
reasoning behind why he's saying this
and
um you know I think it's important to
call out the balaji's bet is like the
best meme of 2023. he was able to
essentially create a meme that has
caused millions of people to now talk
about this idea of hyperinflation bank
failures uh and Bitcoin and I think
that's ultimately what he was trying to
do so if you ask them in a private room
like hey do you really think bitcoin's
gonna be a million dollars in 90 days
he's putting two million dollars on the
line so like he definitely thinks
there's a chance but I don't know if
he's at like 99.999 likely or if he's
what is it what's two million to him is
that a big deal or no
it's hard to tell
um so Balaji before he became known as
the like blasia was right guy uh he
built and sold a number of companies uh
I think at least two that I know of had
nine figure exits like he's like real
right he's a great entrepreneur uh he
worked in injuries and Horowitz for a
while uh he was that coinbase as the CTO
like he's a very real entrepreneur and
investor and so he he's done well for
himself financially but like I don't
care how rich you are like you don't go
publicly bet people two million dollars
on uh Twitter unless you have some
degree of confidence because in some way
like 2 million may or may not be a big
number but like your personal reputation
is you know quote-unquote Priceless and
so like that's basically what he's
staking here is he's using the money to
draw attention uh to what he's saying
but really he's staking his reputation
on something that a lot of people think
is absolutely insane at the moment and
the BET started because this guy Matlock
I actually don't know who I forget his
first name but he basically tweeted
something and said like uh
hyperinflation is not going to happen
and then about uh biology replied and
said I actually think it will happen and
in fact I'll bet I'll take your million
dollar bet that hyperinflation is going
to happen in the next 90 days and this
is related to the Bitcoin or that's
another bet on top of the Bitcoin one
then you wrote this post and you had one
line you had a couple lines in there
that I hated and I hated I mean uh it
was like it stung me uh one of them was
you quoted uh Lenin you know uh uh one
of the folks who ran the Soviet Union
you said there are decades where nothing
happens and then there are weeks where
decades happen you said that and then
you had a few other lines and I started
reading this and I got scared like I was
legitimately scared and I texted you and
I was like is this real and you're like
um maybe maybe not I forget exactly what
you said but uh you wrote this in such a
way that I was I I was fearful yeah so I
definitely don't want to fear Monger but
I do think that uh there have been two
points now in the last three years where
it's like kind of a shake people and
wake them up and be like hey pay
attention right now the first was uh
during March of 2020 uh I wrote a couple
of different pieces people had similar
reactions to it and you know one of the
pieces was like I I basically was
arguing that unemployment was going to
be double digits and millions and
millions of people were going to lose
their uh jobs and I had people like
privately emailing me and be like you
are insane please stop fear-mongering
like this is crazy and then the next
week 6.6 million people filed
unemployment claims right and so like if
Balaji is like a plus I'm like D minus
maybe
analyzing some of this stuff
um but at least what I want to do is
call attention to like hey this is
serious and like you should pay
attention
um because if this goes the wrong way uh
it could be catastrophic not only for
people uh with their personal finances
but also like as a nation and I think
it's also important to call out that
like yes it is important but I don't
think most people want this stuff to
happen right like the United States of
America is this amazing place there's
millions of people around the world that
try to come to this country and it's
because we have democracy and capitalism
and stability and like all the things
that we know make this country great if
we were to lose some of that stuff like
this isn't about a financial product or
an asset going up or down in price it's
like if there is complete chaos in a
country people don't care about what
currency they're holding like they want
guns right and like that's not a world
we want to live in and so I think it's
less about uh kind of finance and kind
of investing and it's much more about
like pay attention to this serious
situation that's playing I think that's
what blogie's doing with this bet that's
what I try to get across with the piece
that I wrote uh last week you also had
this other line where you said bodies
keep floating or you said a friend
yesterday told me bodies keep floating
to the surface meaning the Silicon
Valley Bank that's just one body and
we're going to keep seeing more bodies
and so you like used a language that I'm
fairly on I mean I have a high level
understanding of this stuff so nowhere
close to a lot a lot of smart people but
you use language that that stung me and
when I see people who like you who write
like that it's almost like this is how I
describe Malcolm Gladwell when I read
his books
they're so convincing Tucker Max is
another guy who does this he's they're
so convincing because they're such good
writers and they're so so good at just
explaining their points that I have to
remember that when like a Malcolm
Gladwell book it's like dude this is all
just a a a theory and I could probably
find lots of examples of why he's wrong
but he's so good and you are so good at
writing about it that I I begin to
believe you and I have to like pinch
myself sometimes like wait this is just
his opinion and there's actually people
that are probably equally smart and
equally experienced that have a
different opinion and I find that to be
that whole thing though I find to be
very confusing and unsettling it's um
this Viewpoint that like you want to
argue ferociously one point of view so
that the response both the critiques and
the support is as ferocious back right
if you write a piece in it people are
just like ah whatever like you know I've
heard this hundred times like nobody
even takes the time to respond but on
the internet like you kind of have to go
all in and really argue a point but if
you are intelligent hopefully if you get
new information or you see a critique
that you're like oh that's actually a
great point and you're willing to change
your mind then you can very quickly
iterate your way closer to the truth
it's hard to always get to the truth
um but I think that's kind of why I
write that way is just argue ferociously
and then you'll get the ferocious
response and that will help you get to
the truth faster
what's the best let me ask one more
question about this Sean really quick
what's the best argument as well as the
best person that you like to read that
takes the opposite stance of you that
you can see that you can you would say
if I'm wrong I think this could be true
like who do you who do you like to read
that thinks you're wrong and they could
be right so it's not on every topic
obviously and even in individual
situations I have friends who I agree on
95 of stuff with and then there's that
one thing that they like vehemently
disagree with me on and I actually pay
attention more when they disagree than
to the person who disagrees with
everything right it's like once somebody
has shown that they're a clear thinker
and somebody's able to actually uh think
through individual ideas and they don't
just succumb to like oh Sam and I are
friends we always agree on everything so
like on this new topic I should just
agree with him actually I want to
surround myself with people who they are
very clear when they agree and they're
very clear when they disagree and what
you want to look for is like volatility
in agreement so the more that somebody
agrees with you you pay attention and
put weight on when they disagree and
then the more that somebody disagrees
with you uh that you want to pay
attention when they actually agree so
it's that volatility or that kind of
reversion uh away from the mean that
ends up being important to pay attention
to but who who who who who are those
people in this case is there anyone uh
right now I would say so it's less about
like individuals I think there's a whole
cohort of people uh everyone has kind of
a little bit different view but let me
explain first kind of what's happening
and then it'll help me under uh explain
why I think that there could be a
counter argument to it as well so the
main argument is that if you go back to
the beginning of 2020 uh the economic
and financial system was like pretty
good right unemployment was pretty low
inflation was under two percent like we
were kind of chugging along we've been
in a decades-long bull market everything
seemed fine
um if not good uh obviously covet
happens and the first kind of big shock
to the system was all the government
lockdowns right so across the world
people said hey go sit in your homes
when you do that What's called the
velocity of money or the amount of
Commerce goes down so if you used to go
to the bar if you used to go and buy
stuff at the store like you were just
locked in your house now you're not
spending as much money so when velocity
of money goes down people get scared and
when they get scared and they're fearful
there ends up being something called a
liquidity crisis and the best way to
think of a liquidity crisis is just like
you look at your portfolio assets and
you're like I want dollars I want safety
and so you just sell everything that you
can to try to get dollars so people
didn't care if it was stocks bonds
cryptocurrency if they had liquid you
know real estate assets they could sell
Commodities anything they just sell
everything and they want dollars and so
if you go back and look and March
literally meaning cash in a checking or
savings account so that's like step one
and then if you remember during uh March
and April of 2020 people didn't know
what's going on like I went to the ATM
and I pulled out a bunch of cash if you
were literally pulling physical cash out
they're like well just in case right
like who knows what's gonna happen they
also were like buying toilet paper and
doing all like the crazy stuff because
fear takes over and so when these
liquidity crises happen uh all assets go
down and the dollar becomes stronger and
central banks and governments have to
make a decision they can say hey we
believe in the free market we're just
gonna like let this play out yeah it'll
be painful in the short term but like
the free market will kind of figure it
out over time or they can what they
normally do say we are going to
intervene we're going to stay step in we
can't let our people suffer and so of
course like politicians and Central
Bankers they're very short-term
optimized because there's pain that
millions of people experience on a
day-to-day basis and it's hard to sit by
and watch people suffer so it makes
sense from like a human Viewpoint as to
why they would step in uh although I
disagree that many times they probably
should not step in and so that's what
they did they stepped in they basically
dropped interest rates to zero percent
which just made it incredibly attractive
to borrow money right if people are
borrowing money that means they're going
and they're spending it they're buying
houses they're buying all this kind of
different stuff and then they also
pumped between the central bank and the
politicians trillions of dollars into
the economy one key thing that a lot of
people missed including myself initially
is that regardless of how the money got
into the system the money ended up in
the banks so if they gave 1200 checks to
individuals whether they bailed out the
airline industry whether they created
all sorts of stimulus packages whatever
when people received the money whether
they spent it or they held it someone an
individual or a company put that money
in the bank and so the deposits of these
Banks exploded Silicon Valley Bank is a
great example they had about 60 billion
dollars of deposits to start they ended
up having about 190 billion dollars of
deposits so kind of 3x growth 130
billion dollars or so but what does the
bank do when all of a sudden people show
up like here's 190 billion dollars
they're in the business of making money
and so in a zero interest rate
environment they can't buy short-term
debt right all that means is like
they're buying treasuries that are three
months six months nine months 12 months
two years whatever but all of that
basically has no return because interest
rates are at zero so instead what
Silicon Valley Bank did is they went and
they bought 10-year bonds meaning that
they're going to buy a bond today if
they hold it for 10 years they'll get
back their principal plus whatever the
return on the bond is now that bond that
they were buying had about a 1.5 percent
return right so you buy it today you
hold it for 10 years you're getting your
principal plus the the 1.5 percent uh
type return over that 10-year uh period
which is a conservative play Super safe
super conservative backed by the US
government like everyone looks at
treasuries and like that's the safest
thing to buy right
now that is all good and fine if the
environment continues how it is what
ended up happening is that all that
money got pumped into the system
inflation exploded we had the highest
inflation in 40 years and so now all of
a sudden inflation's at nine plus
percent in the central bank's like oh
boy this is not good we have to bring
inflation down because inflation
actually doesn't hurt rich people rich
people make money on inflation because
they own assets it's the poor people the
bottom 50 they're the ones who get hurt
by inflation so let's try to get
inflation under control and so the way
they did this is they jacked up interest
rates from zero percent to about 4.5
percent and then they started selling
assets off their balance sheet they sold
about a trillion dollars of assets
when they do that basically they are
tightening Financial conditions making
it harder and less attractive to borrow
money spend money what do they sell what
do they sell the Central Bank uh this is
actually a crazy statistic they had
about a 900 billion dollar uh balance
sheet coming out of the global financial
crisis they 10 bagged it they literally
went from 900 billion to 9 trillion
between the global financial crisis in
2022. right so they expanded by buying
all sorts of debt and treasuries and and
various assets and that's how they get
money into the system is they exchange
the dollars for these assets and then
when they contract or they try to make
tighter Financial conditions they sell
all of those assets right or a good
portion of it to kind of get uh to pull
liquidity out of the system
but when they did this the banks are
basically left holding the bag and what
I mean by that is the banks took that
you know Silicon Valley Bank 130 billion
dollars 80 billion of it they bought
these bonds that earn 1.5 percent which
is great in the zero percent interest
rate environment when they've now
increased interest rates to four and a
half percent that bond that you bought
previously is no longer good it's
actually cheap and so it trades lower so
if you spend 100 on the bond now if you
were to sell it to someone maybe you
could sell it for 80 cents so you'd lose
20 percent on that Bond the reason why
that doesn't matter historically is
because the banks actually get special
accounting treatment so let's say that
Sean has a portfolio and in one of them
uh he bought a stock and he spent a
hundred dollars a share right so he
bought a stock for 100 bucks if he goes
to the bank and now the stock is trading
at 80 and he wants to use that stock
share as collateral they don't give him
credit for spending a hundred dollars
they're like hey it's worth 80
bucks like you get credit for eighty
dollars not a hundred
but the banks have a special accounting
treatment where they can actually take
some of the assets on their balance
sheet and they can put it in a special
area and they call it hold to maturity
hold to maturity basically means we get
to count what we bought it for not what
it's worth today and the reason why
they're allowed to do this is because
they can hold the bond until the
maturity the 10-year period and they'll
get the principal plus the return so as
long as they don't sell it before it
matures then it ends up being worth what
they paid for it
the only time that this does not work is
if all of the depositors want their
money back at the same time because now
the banks have to sell all those assets
and take that money to give back to
depositors and that's what happened to
Silicon Valley Bank is basically there
was a bank run when the bank run caused
the bank to sell assets they lost
billions of dollars which then scared
more depositors so then they went and
said hey give me my money back and it
just became this reinforcing cycle and
in 24 hours 42 billion dollars was
drained out of the bank which caused
them to eventually be insolvent and the
government took it over and ultimately a
great explanation that was awesome you
killed it there biology and a few other
people are betting that that's going to
happen to other more consumer-based
banks in the next 90 days is that right
so it's already happened like this isn't
just a Silicon Valley Bank thing like a
lot of the politicians they this was
like a a softball served up to them down
you know right down the uh plate they
were like oh great the crypto and tech
companies are a bank customer it must be
their fault but like silvergate Bank
Silicon Valley Bank signature bank now
Credit Suisse like these are not you
know crypto Banks or or just Tech Banks
this is a complete Global Financial uh
system issue and now there's reports
coming out that hundreds of banks are
actually underwater in terms of holding
these assets and so that's why you've
seen the central bank and the
governments around the world step in and
say we will backstop a lot of these
deposits because they don't want people
to be so scared that they go in the try
to take their money out of the banks
because if everyone goes to do that that
then basically creates a Cascade of Bank
runs and so balaji's argument and why
he's making this bet is that when the
government steps in to protect the
depositors that is an inflationary
pressure and it's going to take
trillions and trillions of dollars to do
it and so at the same time you're
getting trillions of dollars of
inflationary pressure you also are
getting this psychological Awakening and
people are saying wait a second maybe
the dollar isn't as strong as we thought
it was I should look for an alternative
and when those two things happen
hyperinflation can occur doesn't
guarantee it but it can occur and I
think really if you kind of boil down
his entire argument and why he's created
this essentially meme with the bit
signal is that people in the United
States we've never worried about this
but this is not new globally there are
people listening to this podcast right
now they'll tweet at us afterwards
they're like dude I live in Argentina
like inflation's like 70 80 year over
year I live in Venezuela I live in
Zimbabwe I live in all these countries
where they live with hyperinflation on a
day-to-day basis it's just that in the
U.S we've never thought about it and
then two is like you come you add
complexity because the United States
dollars the global Reserve currency so
if we screw this up so bad that we
hyperinflate the dollar
I don't even understand I don't think a
lot of people understand like what
happens globally when the global Reserve
currency hits high inflation or
hyperinflation so again it goes back to
like we don't want this to happen but
damn people should be paying attention
right now to make sure that they
understand what's occurring and kind of
how to prepare for it
I can find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
serve dueling databases HubSpot grow
better
[Music]
so let me uh add a little color on on
what you just said so
um there was a biology tweeted this out
it was just a a like a memo or a note
from the Kansas City office of the
Federal Federal Reserve and they had
said there's kind of this like one
section that he highlighted which it
said
um at year end 2021 since basically two
years ago only four Community Banks were
below the kind of five percent ratio of
uh of their of their assets that they
had available so they were basically
only four four Banks would be at this
threshold that we would be worried about
um
fast forward to today that's now 333
Community Banks in the United States so
333 Community Banks are essentially
insolvent is what this what this means
and could be if there was a bank run on
any one of these we would have the same
problem that we had first at Silicon
Valley bank and then what was about to
happen on you know last Monday or
whatever where everybody was going to go
to you know I know here in California
First Republic Bank was like you know
the Domino that was ready to fall before
they came in and said no no everything's
everything's safe all your deposits are
guaranteed don't worry
um to try to stop that from happening
because there are 333 Banks just in the
United States that they say are below
that ratio now what that would do to the
next tier who knows and also uh overseas
because the the dollar is the the
reserve currency overseas there's a
bunch of banks that hold
um dollars and they're they're worried
about what if there's a bank run on us
um and so like you know just last night
overnight on a Sunday night you know
it's bad when they're sort of working on
a Sunday night and you know making these
announcements uh where they're like oh
we're establishing this like swap line
and it's like what's the swap line swap
line is basically
hey we'll bail you out too so if you
need dollars the Central Bank of the
United States will give it to you to
European Central Bank and all these
other places so they basically
established this overnight back Channel
which said if you need dollars because
you're going to get hit with a run we
don't want you to fall over and cause
this Cascade of fear and panic and and
withdrawals so we will also backstop you
just like we backstopped uh you know the
Community Banks in the United States so
that's to topology's credit I think he
is correctly identified just like he did
with coronavirus that hey this might be
a lot worse than you think
um
and there's actually data to support
that the conditions are worse than you
think now what's funny is
apology actually did this twice so he
had like a V1 of of trying to spread the
word Sam I don't know if you saw this
one so the V1 was he goes the bit signal
he goes how do you raise ring the fire
alarm on the internet how do you show
it's not a false alarm I'm putting up
the bit signal he goes I'll put a
million dollars in Bitcoin to alert
people about this stealth financial
crisis I'll give a thousand dollars to
the best thousand tweets that show a
reply with a graph a stat a meme that
will bring attention to what's happening
because the Central Bank of the banks
and the big regulars have bankrupted us
they're trying to hide the insolvency of
the banks to you the depositor which is
a weird thing to do right that's like
it's helpful that he's he's trying to
help but it sometimes that doesn't help
right this was a pure giveaway right
that's not a bet he said I'm giving away
a million dollars
to the I'll give a thousand dollars to
the Thousand best Tweets that will
spread the word
this tweet did pretty good 13 000 likes
um and he tried but then he hit you with
just like a bunch of like you know
things that topology is like Light
reading but to the rest of us it's like
oh man like I gotta you know I gotta
hook up to an oxygen tank just to intake
this amount of information so it's like
this uh this crazy thing so he'll tweet
this table of like you know 45
currencies that have done hyperinflation
he'll tweet out a thing that basically
shows some random meeting minutes from
the FED in 2022 that showed that they
knew something right like all these
these data points but it wasn't really
going viral until this guy James Medlock
comes out and he goes I'll bet anyone a
million dollars the US does not enter
hyperinflation and James Medlock by the
way I think by the way he had it it was
even scarier I think he said everything
that we're talking about by the way it's
in within 90 days of like last week
right no no first it was just said I'll
bet anyone one million dollars hyper
reflection doesn't happen Okay that was
just that was that guy sweet apology
just takes this random by the way I I
interrupted you say who he is say who he
is I don't know who this guy is is
Democrat markets the market is Market
socialist in the sheets I don't know
what this guy's talking about this guy's
like it's a meme account it looks like
so um you know he's got a picture that I
I don't know who this is a million
dollar bets yeah exactly the email is at
mastodon.lol okay so like let's be real
what's going on there so biology comes
out he says I will take that bet you buy
one Bitcoin and I'll I'll send one
million dollars to an escrow
to be clear This is 40 to 1 odds so he's
basically saying not only is this
unlikely to happen like if this was even
odds it would have been like dang
apology is going to lose a million
dollars because bitcoin's not likely to
be worth a million dollars then he added
in 90 days which is already a radical
move then he said
I'm and by the way the million dollars
versus one Bitcoin Bitcoin is currently
at 26 000 at this at the time he made
this bet he goes That's 40 to 1 odds
that I'm laying you and he says all we
got to do is find some you know a
mutually agreed on like escrow or
custodian
um and he again he tweets out this bit
signal graph and so he's like you know
I'm doing this again now this this tweet
goes viral this one gets 11 million
views because it's more provocative it's
it lets anybody at first the wave of
tweets myself included was like biology
is nuts he's gone crazy uh like this
doesn't make any sense and uh and so you
know because it was like Not only was
the BET unlikely to prove in his favor
it was a perfect bet for Mr you know
James Medlock over here the social the
Democrat in the streets and the
Socialists and the sheets all he had to
do was buy two Bitcoin right he could
buy one that he's putting up for the BET
and if he's wrong and Bitcoin and the
dollar does hyperinflate Bitcoin becomes
worth a million dollars all he had to do
was buy a second one so if he could for
52 000 he could guarantee himself a
Million Dollar Payday so it was like an
absolute no-brainer and you know the
poker player in me was like balji what
are you doing that's a you've given this
guy like a you know a no lose bet and so
I messaged him and I was like uh you
know hey apology this is crazy what are
you what are you thinking and here's
what he here's what he replied I I think
I could share this because it's not uh
not anything that he's not tweeting out
he's tweeting all this stuff out anyways
so it's not it's not overly crazy but
here's what he said
so he goes he just replies all the banks
are insolvent that was the first first
reply he goes have you seen The Big
Short where one guy figured something
out early and everybody else thinks he's
crazy
that's what that's what's happening here
he goes uh people think this is a single
bank issue like Silicon Valley Bank it
was a central bank issue all the banks
are dead 10 day days ago there were no
dead Banks today there are five and if
people realize this in the start to pull
their money out they'll realize that the
banks don't have it it's Uncle Sam
bankman freed not Uncle Sam
which is what basically what happened
with FTX people realize the money's not
in the the money's not in the in the
bank with FDX and then that caused uh
you know the extreme crash
um and then he tweeted out a bunch of
stuff and he goes uh he goes I'm not
doing he goes yes I'm not doing this to
make money because I pointed out that
the guy could just hedge and win the bet
he goes yes I'm not doing this to make
money he goes if I had the beliefs that
I do and I was just purely selfish I
would simply just take the million
dollars and buy 40 Bitcoin I would take
you know another million dollars buy
another 40 Bitcoin and I do it quietly
because I believe that the US that the
million dollars is going to be worth
zero in 90 days I'm doing this to alert
innocent people and to send a message
get to the exits and so I want to bring
up a couple of like cases here so that
that's the best hold on really really
quick there's also this other thing
apparently right around this time
there's a picture of him so this guy
biology he's like has this like a
picture on the YouTube video gotta throw
out the picture so he's got the
stereotype of being like you know like
the forgetful scientist of like he's
just this guy who only cares about being
brilliant and oftentimes he's right and
he's eloquent whatever
there's a picture of him it looks like
he's giving a seminar at like a
university
and someone tweeted he goes biology is
uh saying get the F out of the U.S and
it's and it's very scary and he's
sitting there giving this presentation
in front of like a class and he's
wearing pajamas like a like a pajama
looking hoodie uh basketball shorts and
Nike Air Jordan flip-flops with his
laptop sitting on top of like two
cardboard boxes and so if you needed
like this this
any more of this stereotype of this like
brilliant like you know of this uh the
the image that we have of Mark
Zuckerberg you know just sitting in a
hoodie coding eating pizza and drinking
Red Bull biology is going all in on that
image uh and it it almost makes it worse
when I see this picture but but I think
a lot of uh why he has so much
credibility is that he has been able to
identify a number of these like
exponential uh situations and if you
really think about uh what he's saying
here it's almost an exact overlay to
covet right he saw very early on a
couple of data points and he was able to
extrapolate from a couple of those data
points hey this isn't a linear line like
this is literally an exponential curve
and the top of the exponential curve is
really scary like let me go yell scream
and like call attention to it he's doing
the exact same thing here and I think
that's uh what Sean was reading about
like hey 10 days ago there was no dead
Banks now there's five like he's just
trying to put a couple of data points
and be like if this goes exponential
like this is really bad and I think that
one of the the components uh that's
important to call out is like I don't
know what the percentages of Americans
but most Americans don't know that if
you go and you deposit your money in the
bank it's not your money anymore
right like just that alone like the the
lack of financial education of the
average American is astonishing and so
yes there's FDIC insurance that covers
up to 250k like there's all these
different things but if you go look
right now like the FDIC does not have
enough money to backstop every Bank in
America
or something I think the 20 of it was
used to help Silicon Valley Bank yeah
that's Silicon Valley Bank yeah Silicon
Valley Bank is like the 20th largest
bank in America yeah so it's like not
not very big compared to the big big
ones one other thing that I think is
important to understand about these
situations
um is this idea of like a digital
catastrophe and this is a concept that
uh Frank I struggled a little bit to
come up with like a good name for it but
I think digital catastrophe kind of
really articulates it uh as best as I
can which is you need to understand this
concept because it is going to become
very very common in our lives over the
next you know 20 30 40 years but the way
that I Define a digital catastrophe is
it's an event that occurs that is
negative usually plays out in the analog
world World kind of the real world but
it is drastically accelerated by the
speed of communication and action online
and so Silicon Valley Bank is like the
prime example right if you think about
what happened there on Wednesday
afternoon they made an announcement by
Thursday morning people were scared by
Thursday afternoon 42 billion dollars
had been withdrawn from the bank and by
Friday morning the bank was dead right
so like in 48 hours it was the second
largest banking failure in the United
States history but in the old days what
you would have to do in order to have a
bank run is like Sean would walk over to
Sam's house and be like yo Sam did you
hear like the bank's probably not doing
so hot and then like Sam be like huh
that's kind of crazy and you would walk
ride your horse maybe get in the car and
like show up to the bank physically wait
in line and be like when you get to the
teller window can I have my money back
like that takes a lot of time effort
energy all that type of stuff now
you can literally open a new tab on your
browser click a couple buttons and move
your money
and so when the speed of information
occurs that it does on the internet
millions of people whether you're a
customer Silicon Valley Bank or not like
Twitter knew that the bank was insolvent
by like noon on Thursday
right and so if that happens that's how
you get 42 billion dollars withdrawn
from a bank that is a digital
catastrophe it's the speed of
information the speed of action online
has real world consequences and so
another way to think about it is like
the internet was weaponized to create
the second largest bank failure in
history but it was in response to the
knowledge of an insolvent bank that was
caused by a fractional Reserve banking
system and an increasing of interest
rates that basically left the bat uh the
bag holders as the banks and so people
were just operating out of personal
incentive to get out of the way
yeah there's a
there's a it was kind of amazing like a
Thursday morning I remember waking up
and in our group chat Sam there was like
somebody posted Silicon Valley Bank
stock was going down
uh I was down like 30 or 40 percent it
was like oh wow I must have had a bad
earnings call right or you know that was
kind of my assumption it wasn't anything
too too bad
uh you know by 11 or noon I'm scrolling
Twitter and I start to see you know if
you scroll that this is just a general
truism if you scroll social media and
you see four or five different sources
talking about the same thing your brain
is just like wired to be like this is
now a this is a big deal topic X is a
big deal marketers use this to their
advantage when they want you to like
Bunko buy a product or know about a
movie that's coming out or whatever they
do the same thing that's why they get
why influencer marketing is a big deal
but it also works just organically five
people say the same thing on in one
Twitter scroll I know that something's
up and so I remember being on the phone
and basically in the manner of like 15
minutes it was like I'm on the phone
we're not even really sure what to do
it's like uh let's just be safe take it
out sent in emails to you know sent an
email saying hey we're taking it out
opened up a new tab clicked wire the
money
took a screenshot of the wire sent it
back into six group chats then went
ahead and tweeted out a thing dude it's
like wow like in 15 minutes I just like
propagated this more than I could have
done if I if it had been my full-time
job you know 20 years ago which is kind
of what to your point and uh and the
funny thing is people are mad that like
um they're like well if there wasn't a
bank run there would have never been a
problem
and it's sort of like uh it's you know
they use this example of like what's it
called like screaming fire in a movie
theater or something like that it's like
then everybody runs the exits well the
reality is if there's no fire in the
theater
um Everybody Run to the exits and
getting stuck there then you know trying
to get out like it's not that big of a
deal there was actually a fire and so
like you know I don't know how the blame
gets shifted to the people who
successfully gotta got out of the fire
versus uh pointing out that hey somebody
caused this thing to catch fire which is
kind of biology's Point biology he
tweets out this graph of
the like the the balance sheet or
whatever it's basically like goes up up
up up which is like during the money
printing era then the last year year or
so it's been trying to tighten so it's
been going down it's been contracting
and then like overnight it just goes
straight up vertical like no graph
you've ever seen because it's two
trillion dollars was basically of
liquidity was added to the market now
some people say
no it wasn't really like put into the
supply like pop you might have an idea
about this some people say well that two
trillion dollars has not really being
given out it's not going into the supply
it's kind of just there as a borrowing
facility in case the banks need it in
order to like prevent any Panic
um and other people say money particular
Bird that's the same thing so you know
what are you talking about here I don't
know do you have an opinion on that
you know when you're in like high school
and uh there's the like but actually kid
in class who like sits there in the
corner and no matter what anyone says
like but actually and they try to tell
you about something they read or this or
that or whatever it's actually called
Barcelona
[Laughter]
exactly right Oh you mean bruschetta no
I mean bruschetta Karen like that is
those people on the internet right these
people who uh they're the same people
during covid that were like uh but
actually and then they would go on some
ranch right like no the government
locked us in our homes and literally
printed trillions of dollars and created
40-year High inflation and absolutely
screwed millions of people I don't care
what but actually you have to say and
then you look at the same situation as
like they were like but actually
inflation will be transitory and it will
come back down right and then you're
like no that's not how this works and so
ultimately what you end up having which
makes markets so like this is a part of
capitalism is you have Theory meet
reality sometimes theory is a great
primer an overlay on reality and other
times it's not and what I've learned
over time is that the more complex the
system the less likely it is that the
theory overlays perfectly on reality and
like there is no more complex system
than the economic economic system of
America let alone the world and so all
these people who are like oh inflation
will come down because the FED will do
this or that well like the FED isn't the
only thing that contributes to inflation
their supply chain disruptions there's
geopolitical war there's like all these
different components to it and so I
think that you've got to be very careful
just looking at Theory and trying to
impose Theory onto reality but the other
thing that I would say throughout this
entire uh kind of cycle or or uh you
know kind of news development
man are we lucky we have the internet
like the internet is the greatest place
in the world and like Sean did a great
job explaining you know you can
propagate some of this information but
imagine being in the 1950s or 60s and
like you basically could read the
newspaper and maybe you watch like the
nighttime news and you have to listen to
the talking points from the like public
narrative or like the you know the the
government or uh the fed or whatever
on a daily basis there are things that
are said by uh those who who kind of set
the public narrative and within seconds
people on the internet destroy the
narrative and they're like nope that's
not true here's these five points and
like I don't care necessarily who's
right or wrong every single time as much
as it's like I want both sides I want
what the people in charge are saying and
then I want the people who like think
the people in charge of idiots are
saying and then I'll kind of like think
for myself but the internet is what has
empowered that and so like wow what an
amazing time for us to be alive to have
that ability because literally two
generations ago they didn't have like
what are you gonna do go to the
encyclopedia and look up like what is a
bank run right or like how does Central
Banking work it's just amazing that we
now have this capability so to I think
we should wrap this segment up and I
want to wrap it up by each of you in
just a couple sentences saying what do
you think is going to happen in the next
90 days and what do you are you guys
doing anything
Sean you go first
okay so I'm gonna say uh two things I
think in the next 90 days
um I basically I think biology is
actually correct on everything except
for his 90-day point because I think
that's too hard to know and uh he might
end up being correct that something
happens in the next 90 days or it might
take 900 days and I think either way the
important part is he's right it's just
the time the time window I think makes
things impossible but the good news is
you don't actually need to know the time
window to act accordingly I I've said
this for a very long time and I think
what biology is saying is a much louder
better version of that which is for a
long time people thought
um if you're buying Bitcoin you're
trying to make a buck
and from the beginning once I started to
understand what is this I was like oh
this is not about making money it's
about saving money it's a savings
technology which is basically to say
even when inflation was only two or
three percent if you just look at two or
three percent over a 40 or 50 year
period
the money that you have in the bank will
still if you put a hundred thousand
dollars in the bank it'll still look
like a hundred thousand dollars but it
will only have the buying power of
something that's sixty thousand dollars
for example and so why would you ever
save your money in something that is
designed
to lose purchasing power you wouldn't
like you wouldn't do that and so I don't
think that it's a uh as I've always
thought Bitcoins the core value of it is
it's a savings technology it's a
currency whose one big feature is it
doesn't inflate
and so you know if you wanted to save
your money you'd rather save your money
in something that doesn't inflate cannot
inflate versus something that either
inflates slowly or quickly right low
inflation or high inflation I don't want
any inflation if I'm saving my money and
so anyways I think that he is correct
about if you're going to save money you
should do it in a hard currency that's
not going to inflate I've already been
on this bandwagon obviously been the
kind of crypto person that's uh you know
obviously a believer in crypto created
the milk road because I believe in
crypto still believe in crypto and so
nothing has really changed there in the
next 90 days I would guess that biology
looks like a fool because people are
going to point out that it didn't happen
in that time period but in the next 900
days I think that he will be proven
correct in 30 seconds pop what do you
think or 60 seconds I think that Balaji
is correct similar to Sean the timeline
is hard to get there I will put a higher
probability on the 90-day timeline than
most because I do think that there's
tail risk and mainly it's because when
hyperinflation happens it happens very
fast like in episodes of hyperinflation
everything's fine 90 days later there is
hyperinflation so it's less about like
has this ever happened and it's more
about like is it going to happen uh
again I'm like maybe five percent
because I do think there's very
systematic uh problems and issues
currently in the Global Financial system
I do think that the banks or the central
banks when faced with save the bank save
the dollar will save the banks which
will lead to inflationary pressures uh
but I would not bet a million dollars
that Bitcoin will be a million dollars
in 90 days whew are you guys hyped up or
what I'm ready to go get another fight
we should say you say one thing which is
the the the the the other take that
people have on this which is that if
biology has like a hundred million
dollars of Bitcoin he doesn't need to be
right for this to be a profitable bet
for him so if he's got 100 million
dollars of Bitcoin already Bitcoins uh
Bitcoins up like 20 last week or
something like that but it's up like you
know four or five percent right now
um you know he basically would only need
to move it by like three percent or it
only need to move up by three percent in
order for him to be profitable losing 2
million USD if he's got 100 million
dollars a Bitcoin which I suspect that
he does have 100 million dollars a
Bitcoin I I think he now has moved 90 I
think he said this he's moved 99 of his
net worth into crypto
um and so so I I don't think I think he
can be directionally I think he can lose
the BET and still make money and be
doing the thing that's you know to his
beliefs the right thing to do which is
alert people that the that the banking
system is uh is currently broken and um
and you know he is the Michael burry of
of our industry so we'll see if he's
correct dude I just feel like I drank
just drank like a liter of Mountain Dew
I'm just like drinking buckets of do I'm
just like people want to understand now
when pomp tweeted out that he's coming
on people wanted to know
how are you gonna sit in a room with the
two of us and still be sitting there in
cash
ETFs and not own any crypto at the end
of this segment well hold on 15 minutes
of hell are you in on are you gonna go
buy Bitcoin or what
I own Bitcoin I own uh not that I own it
from 2015
I've made purchases uh and um
I don't have cash I have real estate and
I have but here's the thing though which
is in hyperinflation periods I own
equities those also go up I don't you
know to get to a million dollars Bitcoin
right now is at twenty seven thousand
you know that's like uh what's that like
50x or something I don't know if
equities well 50x but I I mean they they
will go up yeah maybe but also all those
businesses run in dollars and all their
earnings are in dollars if dollars are
not useful anymore right like the whole
system that's the thing I'm a Bitcoin
Bull and you don't want to see this
happen because the world will will be
chaotic absolutely chaotic it will be
bad for a lot of people I think
everybody even who's the biggest Bitcoin
Bulls you said this yourself pump
you're not rooting for for it to happen
this way a slow transition is really the
only thing you want a fast transition
would create a lot of damage and so you
don't really want that to happen
[Music]
foreign